And answer is the second choice. It is also
true that there's a small town in Virginia named
Alta Vista. But the relevant answer is the second
choice. Back in 1998, the most popular search engine was
probably the search engine called AltaVista. They certainly had
the biggest web index at the time. And they also
had great technology for responding to queries quickly. 1998
is the year that Google was founded, and most people
probably have not heard of AltaVista today, and, might
have had a hard time answering this quiz. And
the reason for that is Google figured out a
better way to do page ranking. And because of this,
search engines that didn't have good ways of ranking
pages, like AltaVista, quickly become irrelevant. And the algorithm
that I've described, is the algorithm that launched Google.
It's called PageRank. And you may think the Page stands
for webpage. The Page actually stands for Larry Page, who was
the co-founder with Sergey Brin, of Google. So, that's the algorithm
that we've described. And that's what allowed Google to produce so
much better search results, than other search engines at the time.
>> I hope you remember Anna Patterson from Unit Three, and are still following
her advice to be polite on the web. One of the reasons AltaVista started to
work so badly, was because websites were not polite. They
tried to find ways to gain the rankings. Certainly this
is still something websites still do today. And the way
AltaVista ranks pages, it was very easy to gain them, so
the site that would be ranked was not the best
site about something, but a site that was best at gaining
the rankings. So I asked Anna to explain why Google's
page ranking algorithm was so important to the success of Google.
>> So a page rank on the web, was a huge step forward.
I'm old enough to actually remember the time
that Google launched and you know, it's advance over
AltaVista. Was AltaVista was very, very prone to keyword
stuffing spam. So if you said restaurant 32 times,
well you were better than a page that
said restaurant twice. So, PageRank came out and actually
gave a measure of popularity or traffic, and therefore,
the things that said restaurant twice, but were awesome.
They wound up going to the top.
>> Certainly things have got more complicated since then, and there's
more things that go into the ranking algorithm, than just what we've
shown you. But that's the basic idea, and the next thing
we're going to do, is change our search engine to implement this algorithm.